seattle-tacoma International Airport is
stepping up security after an airline
employees stole a passenger plane there
Richard Russell crashed and died after a
joyride that lasted more than an hour a
SeaTac spokeswoman calls the flight a
one-in-a-million experience but the
airport is making its cargo areas and
passenger terminals more secure Kris Van
Cleave spoke to the head of the TSA
about the incident he's at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington DC
Chris good morning good morning
Friday's theft of an airliner by Richard
Russell is raising new concerns about
so-called
insider threats and raising a lot of
questions about how airport workers are
vetted three days after horizon air
employee Richard Russell took control of
an unoccupied commuter plane from the
SeaTac Airport Port of Seattle
executives defended the airport
screening procedures we have always met
all federal security protocols but we've
always gone beyond when necessary
Commissioner Courtney Gregg Wars said a
review found all security protocols were
properly followed before Russell gained
access to the plane and took off I got a
lot of people that care about me and
it's going to disappoint them
to you that I did this rustle past
federal criminal background checks that
look back 10 years and had no links to
terrorism he was one of more than 12,000
people with access to the airfield at
sea-tac for me it's really more of an
issue of of access and appropriate
access irregardless of of what the
intent of the actor is David pukowski is
the TSA administrator is this something
that should be a wake-up call for
airports airlines in your agency it's
certainly not a new issue at all for any
of us this highlights an additional
vulnerability and it's something that
really I'd just like to see the entire
facts set the aviation industry has long
worried about insider threats linked to
terrorism but in 2012 a Skywest pilot
suspected a murder failed to takeoff and
crashed an empty plane at a Utah Airport
before killing himself and three years
ago in Europe a Germanwings pilot
suffering from depression intentionally
flew a plane into a French mountainside
killing 149 others can you screen for
things like mental health in an
effective way with regard to mental
health I mean we do do do screening in
terms of background checking for all
airport workers but the background
checks they look at criminal records
those look at ties to terrorism and
watch lists are you checking for any
signs of mental illness or other
disqualifying factors what we did right
now in the background checks is you're
right we look for for criminal history
and any connections with terrorist
organizations and with this particular
case I mean let's let the investigation
run its course and see what the entire
facts said is
senator Maria Cantwell of Washington
state is already calling for
congressional hearings about what
happened at sea-tac horizon is owned by
Alaska Airlines Alaska says it is
cooperating with investigators to
determine how this happened and how it
can be prevented Gale that's a very
scary thought thank you very much Chris
I don't know how you get around an
inside job when somebody who had all the
proper access does something that goes
so Road very very frightening
they wonder about copycats and your
potential yeah that's out there clean